well let's take a look at what's going
on below the surface of the meeting
today between zelenski and sunak the
security and defense analyst Professor
Michael Clarke is here with me at the
big screen Michael good to see you as
always a bit of a surprise this visit
um solinski's Come Away with more air
support not quite what he wanted though
uh what was his reason for for coming to
the UK today yes and I mean he he said
to Richardson like I'm sure things you
said on the telephone many times they
didn't need to say the things they will
have said but he came again with this
demand for air power now the British are
very sympathetic to this there's certain
things we can do and we've said I mean
announced today that the Britain will
establish a pilot training scheme just
as we're training infantry and so on
what they really want is the F-16 now we
don't have f-16s we don't run them here
in this country but there are many of
them in Europe and a lot of European
countries want to give f-16s to Ukraine
but the Americans won't allow it because
it's an American aircraft and the reason
that they want f-16s is because the
balance is changing there's a sort of
microcosm here if we look at the air
battle because the ukrainians have been
given Storm Shadow last week the British
gave them stormshower there it is on the
top left there carried under the under
the fuselage of of a a NATO Jet and
Storm Shadow worked very well it was
announced on Thursday it was in action
by Friday and the reason it was so
effective is this which is that it's
called this is the the
um miniature air defense decoy and this
is another missile American missile and
there's no explosive in it it's just a
decoy it can make itself look like three
or four aircraft going in different
directions it can make yourself look
like different missiles it confuses
defenses and it actually opens up a
certain electronic Corridor through
which Storm Shadow goes so Storm Shadow
plus this very effective so this is top
of the range military stuff from the
west and it works clearly it works and
we'll see a lot more of this in the days
to come but this is what zielinski is
saying look the problem I've got now is
this bottom left it's a Glide bomb the
Russians have worked out that take an
old-fashioned bomb put Wings on it give
it a guidance system and instead of an
aircraft just dropping it it can
actually Glide about 40 kilometers so
the aircraft doesn't need to come very
far into Ukrainian airspace to drop it
and these Glide bombs are causing the
Ukraine's real problems and so zelinski
is saying we've got to actually do
something about these Glide bones with
an air-to-air combat we need the
aircraft not next year which is what
you're talking about we need them now to
stop the Russians as we're flooding us
with cheap very destructive Glide bombs
because we've got to get to the aircraft
that are dropping them problem with that
is that the aircraft that are dropping
them are close to Russian airspace and
might even be over the other side of
Russia's border so the danger of f-16s
that they'll end up fighting over
Russian territory not just Ukrainian
territory that's why the Americans are
so nervous yeah um that's the Diplomatic
part of it all isn't it and as president
zelenski said today there are more
decisions and more discussions to come
as they work towards what he termed a
jet Coalition the first time we'd sort
of heard that phrase today and let's
talk about what this image behind us
here this meeting at Checkers what kind
of message that sends to the Kremlin
today exactly so all the Western leaders
are saying look these these weapons
we're sending are only part of a more
complex message we want the kremely to
understand that we're in this for the
long term and there's a series of
meetings coming up and they want these
meetings to have a big impact so the the
EU are meeting as part of the Council of
Europe meeting this week in Reykjavik
and they're going to be chasing
sanctions Busters so they're going to
actually tighten sanctions on those
companies that are sending uh stuff
indirectly to Russia going to try and
put them out of business in some respect
the G7 are meeting in Hiroshima in Japan
they'll be giving the same message
Britain is hosting in June the recovery
conference and Russia sunak I think
spoke about that this morning said we're
gonna we're gonna really push this
conference the nature of somebody in
July I'm Vilnius that's a critical
meeting leading up to the U.N general
assembly in New York in September at
which we'll make the case again to the
global South that you've got to come on
board with all of this so the Diplomatic
message behind all these weapons is
actually that there's a big political
push on to show that we are in this for
the long term we're not going to walk
away from Ukraine in the short term yeah
long-term diploma efforts and let's talk
about what's going on in the ground
because you know day after day there's a
war going on it's been ground out and
talk to us about where we're at at the
moment yeah we're all Fed Up of looking
at this map in a way but things are
moving in in bhagmat
um I mean this is the the place where
the ukrainians have decided to at least
make uh some pushback and they're
pushing back
um in the north at uh but in ifca and
they've moved troops in towards Buddhist
because the little Villages either side
of the center of bakmut and they've
moved troops to venuska and they've
taken those areas and they've relieved
this this is the key road we keep
talking about the t0504 and they've
pushed South they've actually taken some
prisoners to the South there was a
little Enclave of Russian troops and
they got round them and took them
prisoner and so the ukrainians are
pushing north and south of bakmut which
will take some of the pressure off but
this isn't the main offensive and the
ukrainians have said themselves this is
the Prelude to the main offensive they
want to save back mud for symbolic
reasons and they'll try to convince the
Russians that they need I'm sure to
reinforce back much whether they will or
not we don't know but this offensive is
getting off to a rolling start so you
know when you ask me where is the
offensive I'd say ask me in two weeks
time